In a prison in Seattle the color pink was used
as mind control...
How does this make you feel?
Does it make you feel… passive?
Make a fist. Does it feel...weak?
Drunk Tank Pink, Passive Pink, Cool Down Pink
Baker Miller Pink, P618, whatever you call it
the idea that pink might make you weak is actually science...
kinda
So in the 1960s the scientist Alexander Shauss wanted to find out if colors could effect the way you felt
He was a believer in this German theory that you could
use the colors people chose as a way to understand their inner mental state
and he wanted to see if he could reverse it
if he could basically make you feel things
by showing you certain colors
and he came across one shade that was special
So he got 153 volunteers
and he had them hold out their arms in front of them
and he showed them either a blue piece of cardboard or a pink piece of cardboard
and he had a volunteer push their hands down as hard as they could
151 of 153 people were wea ker when they were looking at pink
he also tested this with slightly more scientific methods
of having people use a hand grippy thing
that tested how hard they gripped
he found a loss of strength between 6 and 23 percent
it had effects on peoples cardiovascular system
they calmed down
so he started taking about this
at one of his talks, two guys, Baker and Miller saw his presentation
they happened to run a prison, this is actually a Naval prison
and they said “Hey, what if we paint the drunk tank pink?"
That’s what they did!
So the Navy’s report was that
Since undertaking this experiment on March 1st, 1979
there have been no incidents of erratic of violent behavior during the confinements
And if you have ever wondered...
What to do with a drunken sailor, what to do with a drunken sailor, what to do with a drunken sailor
put him in a pink room
As far as they were concerned, it was a huge success
and this caught on
penal systems around the country began painting rooms pink
San Bernadino in California painted their juvinille detention center pink
and said the couldn’t leave the delinquent in there for too long
or they would become “too weak”
and the power of pink became one of these well known truths
about ten years later in 1988
so scientists tried to replicate the results
and they couldn’t do it
they could not show any measurable differences in grip strength
in heart rate, it was a wash
but the cat was out of the bag
to this day prison systems are still experimenting with Baker Miller Pink
Switzerland just painted parts of eight different prisons this shade of pink
while the science on this remains pretty sketchy
uses for Baker Miller Pink have been proposed from
corporate break rooms
to the inside of ambulances
panic rooms
airport security
for mental facilities
for catastrophe areas, like natural disaster relief areas
regardless of the science behind it
for modern day prisons
the color of control is pink
bright bubblegum pink
the pinkest pink you can pink
click here to subscribe
or click here to watch our other videos
There is an irony in this too, in that our cultural associations with pink are new
in the turn of the century pink was the traditional boys color
Like what if it’s true and pink actually creates passivity
and it has been thrust upon the women of the world
as a way to make the docile consumers of home goods and dolls
our daughters are being brainwashed by pink!